the pandemic in india has taken a huge
toll on human lives but
it's also placed a massive burden on
people's finances
in the scramble for medical care during
india's devastating second wave of
infections
many people could only find beds in
private hospitals
and for some that's where the financial
trauma began
kavajit singh no longer sleeps well he
says he frequently thinks about his wife
man kirat
who he lost during india's deadly second
wave of kovitz 19.
the entire family was infected but
mankind's health
soon worsened and she was admitted to a
private hospital
singh says the first shock of losing his
wife was bad enough
the second was the hefty bill the
hospital handed him
for a salaried middle class family in
india
a bill of 22 000 euro
is terrifying and i
must say that both emotionally
as well as financially we were not
prepared
to deal with these shocks sayings is one
of many cases of over inflated billing
by private hospitals during the pandemic
reports suggest that many people went
bankrupt while trying to pay for medical
treatment required due to post-covert
complications and long hospital stays
some of them ended up turning to online
crowdfunding platforms such as keto in
this current
ongoing pandemic the way crowdfunding
platforms have come together and
they've helped us primarily for very
expensive medical treatment
where hospital stays are really long uh
and of course where people's insurance
have run out insurance cover has run out
that's where you know crowdfunding
platforms have come and created real
value and
helped a lot of patients this man who
does not wish to be named
resorted to crowdfunding for the
treatment of his sister
this after he had exhausted all his
family's savings
and borrowed money from friends and
relatives she has been in intensive care
at a private hospital for two months
with severe post-covert complications
her bills have already exceeded 50
000 euros when we got my sister admitted
we were told that the government has
ordered a price cap on covet treatment
costs in private hospitals
but when we spoke to the hospital they
told us that the capping
is only for patients who are coveted
positive but the fact of the matter is
the expense of treatment for postcovid
complications
after the patient has tested negative is
ten times higher
kavaljit singh says crowdfunding cannot
be a long-term solution
he says the government needs to enforce
existing rules like capping the price of
covet-treatment costs
since his wife passed away singh an
academic
all his life is now raising awareness
about these issues
within the health care sector see as a
private citizen
i can talk to media i can write an open
article in the media
i can protest i can write complaint
letters to the government but i can't
regulate and supervise private hospitals
that responsibility is not with me that
responsibility lies with the government
singh says he misses his wife terribly
and while nothing will bring her back he
wants to do everything he can
to prevent others from going through
what his family did
with more let's bring in dw
correspondent meniere chaudhry in
delhi monir give us an idea of the scope
of this problem in india how much of a
burden has the pandemic placed on people
there
financially
well especially during and after the
second day we saw multiple reports
coming in our families not being able to
afford medical treatment
when one of their family members got
infected with the karuna virus they were
multiple reports of families resorting
to
selling assets more engaging properties
taking loans borrowing from friends and
families
also because we must remember at that
time at the peak of during the
second wave it's not like people had a
lot of options because reportedly there
was a huge crisis
of hospital beds so people had to resort
to going to the first option they could
get and that
did too many families going to severe
debt
now we heard in your report about one
family facing
a covet-related medical bill of 22 000
euros give us an idea of how long it
would take an average indian household
to pay that back
while assuming i'm assuming we're
talking here about an average indian
middle class family
so we must remember that that that's a
large population
here and also with one earning member
and we must also note that
for that one average indian middle class
family 22
000 euros their annual income is much
less than that figure in fact for a
majority of them their annual income is
even less
than the amount of 22 000 euros so
definitely for families like this
uh the amount like twenty two 000 euros
is much beyond their capacity
the report also mentions a cap on fees
for treating covert patients but that
apparently doesn't apply
to people who are recovering from the
disease are
hospitals exploiting loopholes in
government regulations
well there have been uh people who have
been saying this especially you see in
my report also there's one person who's
getting his sister treated
has had this experience with the
possibility of them that you know that
gap does not apply to
patients who have tested negative enough
and are facing post-school complications
but otherwise too there have been
multiple reports for the past few months
of hospitals not following the
regulations and
regularly flouting the regulations that
the government is placing on them
what efforts are being made maneria to
protect
patients and their families from
financial ruin in this situation
well at the moment if you listen to the
critics and to the activists a lot can
be done and if you listen to kabul
singh who you just saw in my report he's
also trying to raise awareness and one
of the articles he writes that the
government should definitely try to
more strictly enforce these regulations
like that of price capping
also come up with a quick and better
complaint resolving mechanism and also
an
audit committee which could regularly go
to these private hospitals to ensure
that they are not over inflating the
bills
thank you very much that was dw
correspondent manira chaudhary in
delhi
you